MAKE SURE THAT SCAN THE QR
CODE TO FOLLOW THE BRWALKOFF.
NOW, THIS IS MAJOR LEAGUE
WHIFFLE THAT STARTED IN 2009 AND
NOW HAS EIGHT TEAMS AND 50
PLAYERS AND TWO OF THE STARS ARE
KYLE SCHULTZ, THE GOAT, AND
JIMMY NORK, THE SHOHEI OHTANI.
AND LOOK AT THAT, HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HIT THAT?
>> OH, THAT IS A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION.
>> WHY IS THE GUY SWINGING AFTER
IT WENT PAST HIM?
>> WE WILL FIND OUT, BECAUSE
THEY ARE JOINING US HERE.
>> AND THERE IS SHOHEI OHTANI.
AND THE GOAT.
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US,
AND I WILL BE HONEST THAT I DID
NOT KNOW THAT FOR THIS MANY
YEARS, THERE HAS BEEN, AND THIS
IS A PROFESSIONAL WHIFFLE
LEAGUE.
>> IT HAS BEEN CRAZY.
STARTED IN 2009 IN MY FRONT YARD
AND WE HAVE BEEN PLAYING PICKUP
WHIFFLE FOR YEARS AND THEN THE
WORD SPREAD THROUGHOUT MY
COMMUNITY AND BEFORE YOU KNOW
IT, WE HAVE EIGHT TEAMS AND A
REAL LEAGUE GOING.
>> AND IT IS TREMENDOUS AND YOU
MIGHT BE INTERESTED TO KNOW THAT
THIS GUY IDOLIZED YOU.
>> REALLY?
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> CHECK IT OUT.
>> IT IS ALL STARTED THERE.
>> HOW OLD WERE YOU THERE?
>> 8 OR 9.
>> OH, MAN.
TAKING IT WAY BACK.
>> GRAN DIDY, YOU ARE AT THAT PT
NOW WHERE YOU ARE AN IDOL, AND
HE CAN REMEMBER YOUR ENTIRE
CAREER AND QUOTE THINGS THAT YOU
DON'T REMEMBER.
YOU ARE AT THAT POINT.
>> AND I LOVE THAT HE HAS THE
TIGER REPRESENTING AND THE BEST
THING ABOUT THE SIGN IS THAT
BECAUSE MY NAME WAS SO LONG, HE
HAD TO CRAM THE LETTERS ON
THERE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> AND SO, LET'S NOT JUST STAND
HERE, AND LET'S SEE SOME OF THIS
ACTION HERE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE A
QUESTION.
>> YEAH?
>> HOW DO YOU GENERATE SO MUCH
SPIN ON THAT THING, BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN TRYING SOME GRIPS.
AND I KNOW THAT VELOCITY PLAYS A
BIG ROLE, AND SO, I WANT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE ME THROUGH THE BALL
FOR SOME OF THE GRIPS AND SOME
OF THE BREAKS THEY GET, BECAUSE
I WAS TRYING IT, AND I HAVE A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA ABOUT THE BALL,
BUT THIS IS DIFFERENT.
>> JIMMY, DID YOU EVER PICTURE
YOURSELF GIVING A PITCHING
TUTORIAL TO PEDRO MARTINEZ?
>> WELL, THIS IS -- THAT IS WHY
I AM SO INTRIGUED, BECAUSE I SAW
THE MOVEMENT, AND IT IS LIKE,
WHOA, IF I COULD GET A HOLD OF
THE MOVEMENT THERE.
>> MAYBE A COMEBACK?
>> WELL, IF YOU ASKED ME A
COUPLE OF YEARS HOW TO TEACH
PEDRO MARTINEZ HOW THE PITCH, I
WOULD HAVE SAID THAT YOU ARE
NUTS, BUT HERE.
THE HOLES ARE ALWAYS ON THE
RIGHT SIDE FOR A RIGHTY.
SO TO GET MOST OF THE PITCHES I
THROW IT OVERHAND AND NO SPIN OR
FLICK OF THE WRIST EXCEPT FOR
ONE PITCH WHERE YOU PUT IT IN
THE HOLE, AND YOU WILL GET THE
12 TO 6, AND THE HOLES ARE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE AND YOU WILL
FIGURE IT OUT.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT THE AIR,
DOESN'T IT PLAY ANY FACT THERE,
BECAUSE I WAS GRIPPING THIS, AND
I GENERATED A MOVE, AND THEN I
WAS HOLDING IT THIS WAY AND
GENERATING ANOTHER ONE AND THIS
IS WHERE THE AIR ROTATES AND
COMES IN FOR THE RIGHTY AND AWAY
FROM THE LEFTY, RIGHT?
>> THAT IS WHAT YOU SAID.
THE RISER IS LIKE THE FASTBALL
AND IT GOES STRAIGHT UP, AND I
THROW IT WITH THE SIDEARM LIKE
THAT, SO IT IS GOING TO BLOW THE
AIR UP.
>> I PRETTY MUCH UNDERSTAND
THAT.
>> THE SLIDER THE HOLES FACE TO
THE RIGHT SIDE SO THAT THE WIND
WILL BLOW IT LEFT, AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO MESS AROUND WITH THE
HOLES.
>> SO I GET THE PITCHING SIDE,
BUT THE HITTING SIDE.
HELP US THERE.
>> HOW DO WE SWING THAT.
>> COME ON, THERE.
>> YOU SEE THE GUYS WITH THE
LONG HACK, IT DOES NOT WORK.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE QUICK STUDY
THERE, QUICK TO THE BALL.
>> THAT MIGHT BE.
BECAUSE I AM A BIG STRIKE GUY.
>> AND LOOK AT THIS GUY.
>> AND THERE IS -- OH, WOW!
>> LOOK AT THAT.
MORE SPIN ON THE BALL, PEDRO.
>> NOTHING LIKE A NICE BAT FLIP.
>> THOSE THINGS GO A MILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PITCH TO YOUR
IDOL HERE TO GET US STARTED.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS KYLE ON GRANDY.
>> HERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT.
CURTIS.
>> I AM WARMING UP RIGHT BEHIND
YOU JUST IN CASE, YOU RUN INTO
TROUBLE IN THE FIRST INNING.
>> YEP, YEP.
>> DO WE HAVE INSURANCE STILL
WITH TURNER AND TBS JUST SO WE
KNOW, BECAUSE I AM RETIRED NOW.
>> THIS IS WHIFFLE BALL, AND
THERE IS NO CRYING IN BASEBALL.
>> I CAN STAND ANYWHERE IN THE
BOX, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> NORMAL COUNT.
>> REAL COUNT?
>> YES.
>> I WILL GET IT DOWN EARLY.
>> OH!
>> WE HAVE A RUNNER ON.
>> AND HOW ABOUT THAT LOVE?
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO GREW UP
WATCHING ME, AND THIS IS HOW HE
TREATS YOU.
>> OH, NO.
>> OKAY.
TWO UP.
>> THE RISER.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
OFF OF THE PLATE.
>> YOU SEE, I WAS A PATIENT
HITTER AND STILL PASSING OVER.
>> AND THE 0-1 GREEN LIGHT.
>> CAN'T GET IT OVER.
NERVOUS.
>> WE TALK ABOUT THE POST-SEASON
HITTER.
>> I AM THE ONE WHO IS NERVOUS.
HE IS THE HITTER.
>> AND I HAVE TO GET ONE STRIKE
ON HIM.
>> I WILL GIVE YOU 3-1.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> STAND DOWN.
>> HOW ARE YOU TAKING THOSE
PITCHES?
>> I CAN'T SEE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
>> OH.
>> THAT IS THE FULL COUNT.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT WAS A GOOD HACK THERE.
>> ACTUALLY I SAW THAT HACK A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF THE BALL.
>> AND WE GOT THAT SHADOW THERE?
>> I AM THE SHADOW.
>> OH, NO.
>> HE IS FINDING IT.
>> AND NOW, IT IS JIMMY.
>> THAT IS A DREAM PITCH THERE.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> AND NOW, JIMMY.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE READY
FOR IT.
THAT IS MY IDOL THERE.
>> AND NOW, LOOK AT THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
>> SORRY.
>> AND J-ROLL, THIS GUY IS
FILTHY.
>> OH, EJ, YOU KNOW I AM SMOOTH
WITH IT.
>> OKAY.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE.
>> GET'M UP.
>> OKAY.
HE GOING TO GO LEFTY ON ME.
>> RIGHT ON TOP OF THE PLATE,
TOO.
>> OH.
>> I HAVE TO SEE ONE.
GOT TO SEE ONE.
>> YOU HAVE SEEN IT NOW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> TAKE YOUR TIME.
WE GOT TIME.
>> YOU HAVE TO GO LOOK AT THE
SCOUTING REPORT.
>> YOU SEE.
>> THERE IS THE 12 TO 6 WITH THE
FINGER INSIDE OF THE BALL.
>> I CAN SEE THAT.
I DIDN'T FLINCH.
COME ON.
CAN I SEE?
>> THAT IS A GOOD TAKE.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT NONE OF THIS.
NONE OF THE J-ROLL HERE.
I AM DOING A RICKY ON HIM, TOO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU ARE STILL IN IT.
>> 1-2.
>> STILL IN IT.
>> HEY, YOU SURE?
ALL RIGHT.
>> PEDRO, THE 1-2 COUNT, AND
NICE LOOKING CHANGE-UP MAYBE?
>> NO, IT IS LOOKING
SOMETHING -- SOMETHING NASTY.
>> SOMETHING NASTY?
>> NO POOPY PANTS.
>> AHEAD IN THE COUNT.
AHEAD IN THE COUNT.
>> BRING THAT PITCH COUNT UP.
>> OKAY.
2-2
2-2.
>> OH.
>> OH, NO.
2-2, YOU HAVE TO SPLIT IT.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING.
>> SOMEBODY HAS TO FACE PEDRO.
>> AND NOW, THE INNING TURNS AND
WE HAVE TO BRING IN PEDRO.
>> OKAY.
>> LET ME TAKE MY WARMUP TOSSES.
>> THE WARMUP.
>> AND NOW, JUST A BIT OUTSIDE.
>> JUST A BIT OUTSIDE.
>> AND EFFECTIVELY WIDE.
>> OKAY.
GO GET'EM, PEDRO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO, BOYS.
>> PUT THE BALL IN PLAY, AND
GOOD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
>> OKAY.
>> I LIKE TO GET AHEAD.
>> I THINK HE SPIT ON IT.
>> WHOA!
OPPOSITE FIELD.
OH, MAN.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU FALL
BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
>> TAKE THE OUTSIDE CUTTER TO
THE RIGHT.
WE ARE SEEING IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH!
>> COME ON, PEDRO.
>> UP AND IN.
I HAVE SEEN THAT STORY ONE TOO
MANY TIMES.
OH.
>> COME ON NOW, PEDRO.
HE IS THINKING NOW, PEDRO.
>> A LITTLE SHIMMY.
>> OH!
OH!
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND YOU HAVE STRUCK OUT THE
SHOHEI OHTANI OF WHIFFLE.
>> OH, MY.
>> THAT IS WHAT PEDRO MARTINEZ
DOES.
>> OH, WOW.
>> I SAY THAT YOU GOT ONE OFF OF
THE GOAT.
BRAGGING RIGHTS.
>> AND SO NOW A COUPLE OF
REPLAYS.
>> OH.
>> AT LEAST I SWUNG AT THE
STRIKES THOUGH.
>> THAT IS FILTH.
>> THAT IS NOT EVEN HITTABLE.
>> THAT IS THE ONE THAT WAS NOT
FAIR.
>> WHAT ABOUT PEDRO GIVING IT
UP.
>> FILTHY.
>> OH.
>> I AM TELLING YOU.
>> THE ONE THING THAT SETS IT
OFF, THEY HAVE THE HATS AND THE
UNIS, BUT THEY HAVE OFFICIAL
SOCKS.
>> SOCKS.
>> THEY HAVE THEIR OWN OFFICIAL
SOCKS IN WHIFFLE LEAGUE.
>> I HAVE TO GET A PAIR OF
THOSE.
>> THAT IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> THAT IS AWESOME.
>> GUYS, REALLY ENJOYED IT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> GREAT GAME TO ENTERTAIN YOUR
FAMILY AT HOME, TOO.
>> NOW, WILL YOU AUTOGRAPH THE
WHIFFLE BALL FOR